all right let's begin so thank you
everybody for coming to my talk I'll
skip over this intro but today I'll be
walking you through a portion of my
Master's
Theses so I have two goals for this talk
my first goal um is to communicate the
importance of knowing your data before
starting your analysis and the second
lesson I want to leave you um is the
importance of uh first starting with a
mathematical model and framework uh
before diving into your data and trying
to fit a model to your
data so the um so with that for that end
um I'll be walking you through a data
modeling problem um for that I'll be
using data from a trial in London uh
this trial is going to take a subset of
houses in London uh through a particular
uh pricing model and the question is
what is the effect of that pricing model
on uh the consumption of those
households the outline for my talk uh is
first we'll go through the problem space
and the find some terminology that is
going to be helpful along the way um
then we'll go through the trial in the
data set um we'll constru an automatical
model that is going to help us um then
we'll go through data prep cleaning
processing and Analysis and finally
we'll look at the results conclusion um
and some
paps so let's start with some useful
details that are going to be helpful and
you might be asking why is this pricing
model to affect
consumption so electricity is unique in
that it storage is prohibitively costly
so what that means is that supply and
demand must me at all times so um
imagine a state where you have a demand
exceeding Supply and that situation
you're going to have a power outage
power outages are considered to be
extremely costly and so we try to
prevent them as much as
possible so this unique feature of
electricity poses some challenges one of
of these challenges is um imagine you
have an unpredictably hot day there's
unexpected Demand on the grid right so
you have more Demand on the grid than
you expected in that situation you're at
the risk of a power outage and so this
particular feature of electricity makes
it necessary um to have a close to real
time uh methods to to reduce some of
that Demand on the so one of these um
methods is called demand response so as
the name suggest you're responding to
that unexpected demand
so let's go through this visually and
create some sort of an intuition so if
you look at 4M uh the blue line is uh
telling you how much consumption or how
much usage uh is is on the grid so at 4M
uh there's quite a bit of uh Demand on
the grid and it's also beaking and so in
that situation this triggers a demand
response event um and the Shaded green
region is uh the effect of the demand
responsive events uh so that's the
amount of load reduction that you get as
a result of demand
response so demand response can take uh
different ways so you've seen this old
school method of demand response it's
those last texts that you you may have
gotten on a hot day so implicit in
Assumption in demand response is that
there's some fraction of the demand that
is on the grid uh that can be shifted
around right so we just need to uh use
some Tool uh to incentivize people uh to
shift some of that demand
around so another way to do demand
response is use pricing model so um
let's say we have a lot of Demand on the
grid and we want to incentivize people
to consume less right turn down that
electricity um maybe do their their you
know wash their clothes at a different
time and so these pricing models um
increase the price um in those uh times
of high demand and they assume uh that
people are price sensitive and so
they're going to respond to this price
sens price incentive um and as a result
of that uh lower their
INX
there's two um pricing models and demand
response that are used quite often one
is time of use pricing so time of use
pricing has price bands that are preset
uh and times of day that are that are
preset that that's going to be
implemented so let's say um from 6m to
8:00 P.M every single day the price of
electricity is going to be double other
times so that's a time of use uh pricing
model a dynamic time of use pricing
model has price band that are preset but
the time that they are going to be
implemented is dynamic and changes day
over day so Dynamic time we use pricing
is the pricing model that is implemented
in this trial and it's going to be uh
that pricing model whose effect we're
going to try to understand um on the
consumption of this subset of
houses okay so let's uh create our
problem statement and make that more
specific so given the the um goal of
demand response we want to lower
consumption in those uh times of high
demand right and so the effect that we
want to analyze is whether this pricing
model is going to shut demand in those
specific times so it is not an aggregate
that we want a lower consumption it is
in times of high demand that we want a
lower
consumption so in this problem we are
trying to understand the causal effect
of this pricing model on consumption so
with that let's let's try to understand
fality um and some terminology around
that so let's assume that I wake up this
morning and I have a headache so I
decide to take a headache pill I have a
talk and um I wait a little bit and my
headache gets better so the pill that
I'm taking that's the treatment so in
this in this scenario that's called the
treatment or the intervention um in the
case of our trial uh the pricing model
is the treatment or in the intervention
so treatment doesn't necessarily need to
be a an actual medical treatment um it
it is the thing whose impact on some
other thing we time
so the treatment effect is going to be
how much my pain has gone away or how
much consumption um has been lowered as
a result of this
problem I am in this situation the unit
undergoing treatment um and this just
means a single entity um that we are
analyzing as opposed to for example a
population so in this scenario we're
assuming that the the headache pill has
a causal effect on the amount of pain
that I'm feeling similarly we are
assuming that the dynamic time of use
pricing has a causal effect on
cons and lastly there's a reality in
which I wake up in the morning I have a
headache I simply have some water and
wait and my headache gets better but
that's a reality that has not been lived
so we don't know what would have
happened and how my head would feel if I
had not taken the bill and so in that
situation that unlived reality is called
the counterfactual
state
it is not observed it cannot it cannot
be measured so it's just something that
could have happened but we just don't
know so let's put some math to what we
just talked about let's assume X to be a
binary causal variable so that means it
can take two um values you can take the
value zero or one and so in the example
that I just gave x equals to zero is me
not taking the heada F and xal to 1 is
meeting or xal to 1 in our trial is um
going through Dynamic time of use
pricing and xal Z is going through flat
pricing and take y to be the response
variable um so the response variable in
this situation um is going to be the
consumption of these households um and
in the case of the example that I gave
is the level of pain that
I'm and so we're assuming that X has a
causal effect on y take y z to be the
the value of y when X is equal to zero
and y1 to be the value of y when X is
equal to one so here the treatment
effect is simply going to be y1 minus
y0 but given what we discussed y z and
y1 are counterfactuals of each other
right so you can never measure both y1
and Y Z at the same time and get your
treatment effect we can only measure one
in a given time and both cannot be
observed so this is the fundamental
problem of causal inference it makes it
difficult to exactly met treatment
effects but you know we need to
understand the treatment effect in a
whole SCH of problems so there should be
some some solutions around fundamental
problem with causal inputs so one of
these solutions is called temporal
stability and causal transients so what
does that mean temporal stability means
when you apply the treatment it doesn't
matter if you apply it today or tomorrow
it's going to have the same effect so uh
this does not apply in real life that
much so um the treatment that you apply
to a human for example example has some
temporal dependence but let's say we
apply um a particular temperature on
molecules of water it is not depending
on the mood that the water will freeze
or not freeze that is just continually
the case um so it does not depend on
time uh clal transients means uh whether
the treatment that you apply is going to
be reversible right so the the unit
undergoing treatment is it able to reset
back to its original setting this again
is uh something that happens in in a lab
um so for example if I continually take
Pedic pills I will build up some sort of
Tolerance towards
them so the second option is unit
homogeneity what does this mean this
means when I take two units from my
population these two units are going to
be identical and so they're going to
have the same um reaction to the
treatment so um this also is the case in
in lab setting so if I take two
molecules um uh out of like let's say a
population of them uh put one through
the treatment the other not through the
treatment I can observe y1 and Y Z and
get my treatment effect but that is not
the case with households undergoing uh
pricing models or humans undergoing uh
different
treatments and so lastly a solution
around the fundamental problem of causal
inference is to estimate um treatment
effect in populations as opposed to
units in this problem in most problems
involving um humans and households uh
the third option is used can be used but
the the first two options we can
use and so in this problem uh the
fundamental problem of console imprints
makes it so that we need to analyze a
population as opposed to a unit and the
larger the population the more robustly
we can estimate the treatment
effect in addition to that if you have
random samples of populations if it's
going to help you remove the bias in
this
estimate and so let's apply the same
sort of framing that we've been thinking
about to the problem at end so I have a
subset of houses they're going to go
through the treatment um the treatment
being Dynamic time use pricing and I
want to understand the effect of this
pricing model on um their consumption
during these half price points so we
need this other thing called the control
and control group it is another subset
of houses in an ideal scenario they're
both random samples with a high number
of households inside of them um and the
reason that I need it goes back to
control stability um and causal
transients and so with a a single group
because it is temporally dependent and
because you cannot reset back to its
original setting you really can't use a
single group to estimate this treatment
effect so for example if I put a group
of houses through Dynamic time of use
pricing it is possible that that I'm
going to set some habits and so the year
after even if they're not going through
that we are not resetting back to our
original
setting so with this information let's
um look at the trial that um happened in
London so um first of all the trial is
called Low carbon London smart meter
trial um it came out of the climate
change Act of 2008 so um its motivation
is policy based there's a number of
projects that started um as a result of
this and this is one of them the data in
the trial goes between late 2011 and
early
2014 the treatment only took place Cal
in calendar year
2013 and we have half an hour level uh
readings uh for the houses and the
populations um and so that leads to
about 167 million
records so we talked about Dynamic time
of use pricing right so we talked about
the fact that the price Bans are set um
but the times are Dynamic so over on the
left you see the dynamic time of use
pricing bance so on the high level you
have 67 uh Pence per K kilowatt hour and
Pence because this is in London um and
in the normal and low hours you have 11
and four 4 P per Kow hour however in the
static pricing model which is just uh
the the blank slate when you're not
going to the treatment um for the
treatment group and at all times for the
control group uh you have 14 P per kilow
hour so the high price point is quite
high but then the normal and the low are
less than the St price
point okay so let's talk about the
dynamic portion of this Dynamic Time
pricing so we know what the price band
are we just don't know when they will be
implemented so the houses that went
through this treatment got an at home
display and in the middle you'll see
that um they were notified um one day
before the price was implemented what
times the price would be had um so simil
L they can get that over a text and one
thing to look at here is the first text
says um on the 15th your electricity
rate will be high between 5 5 a.m. and
8: a.m. on the 16th they got a text that
says on the 17th the price will be high
between 11:00 p.m. and 5:00 a.m. the
next day and so this is truly trying to
understand how much people are willing
to shift around their demand and how F
sensitive they
are and so um they were notified a day
ahead and we want to understand sort of
their response to to the this Dynamic
high price point the distribution for
the high price point is pretty much
equal so um mostly it happens at the end
of day hours between 4 p.m. and 900 p.m.
and uh this is the time they usually
have a lot of demand off grid so that's
fairly realistic um at least the fact
that it's not um it's more during the
end of day
hours our data set has two other
features um one is the more granular
socioeconomic category that you see so
Acorn group Acorn is this consulting
firm that you designate houses to uh
different socioeconomic categories um
and they've given two designation to to
the houses that exist in this trial one
is more granular than the other
one so this is the distribution um over
um on the x- axis you see the more
granular version um and then the colors
designate the the less gr version so you
have adversity groups Aon groups and
comfortable groups
okay so let's kind of try to understand
our trial a bit more how how were people
onboarded um how did people get into the
treatment group so the trial is double
opin what that means is that you have
people um you have households first of
all opting into sharing their data with
you um and secondly um the treatment
group opted into undergoing Dynamic time
use
pricing in addition to that in addition
to the fact that they opted in which we
creat and biases um there was some cash
incentives that were provided to the
treatment and so that in you can kind of
think about creating some biases in the
population that off into the treatment
group so you can kind of read through
that quickly but ultimately they could
earn as much as 150 pounds for being a
part of the treatment group and
completing uh the
treatment there were some measures taken
um by the people that designed the trial
um to make sure that the two groups are
geographically balanced and also soci
out bounds so we can remove that as
being uh s
bias so the TR started in late 2011
right and it went until um early
2014 so over on the Y AIS you're getting
a count of unque cow IDs that exist in
the data set and so what this is showing
here is that this is when they started
the project they're onboarding users up
until early 2013 and that's kind of when
the dynamic time use price starts and
throughout 2013 some people drop out um
and the third thing to consider is that
you have few people fewer houses um in
the treatment group versus the control
group uh and so as you're going through
the onboarding process you don't have as
many houses as you go through time so
let's go back to the causality portion
of this you're you're analyzing
populations but your population is
changing size um in 2012 and so that
could create some some problems as you
go through the
analysis so let's think about some
reasons uh that the op in aspect could
creat biases so even though our groups
are geographically and socioeconomically
balance we can think of some reason um
that the often aspect could creates en
biases right so let's think about you
know some hypothetical reasons it's
possible that the group that opted into
being a part of the treatment group um
they are more High sensitive than the
other group and so they're able to take
advantage of this pricing model a bit
more it's possible then they're just low
consuming groups and another possibility
is that those households have something
about them so like maybe their their
work hours uh the work that they do um
that they are able to sort of shift
their demand along around uh more easily
than than other
households okay so now that we know our
trial we have some understanding of
causality some understanding of the
problems fa let's formulate a
mathematical model
so let's designate our data um into a
control group and a treatment group
fairly intuitive designation um let's
also divide our data um annually and so
we have alpha y being the control
group's consumption Matrix during the
year Y and beta y being the the Tre MERS
consumption Matrix um and the Air Line
let's kind of think about these matrices
what numbers are in these matrices so
the alpha Matrix is of size T by NC the
beta Matrix is T by n so they're both
they have the time aspect um first and
they have some n and that n is the
number of houses and the groups and so T
is all of those we have half an hour
measurements right so um the T element
is those half an hour measurements that
we have for the year y so for 2012 and
2015 where we have the full year that's
going to be just a half an hour level
interval 17,000 uh temporal components
um uh on the Y AIS and the ends are
different so going back to that plot um
the control group is larger than the
treatment group um so NC and NT is the
only difference between these two
anes let's take beta hat 2013 to be the
counterfactual consumption uh for beta
2013 so what is beta beta is the
treatment group's consumption in 2013
that's the year they went through the
treatment and so going back to our
understanding of what a counterfactual
is we want a counter factual um for this
group to then be able to understand the
impact um of this pricing model right so
we're just going to note that as beta
hat so then our treatment effect is
going to be beta hat minus beta so
that's going to be what it would have
been minus what it actually was and our
goal here is to estimate um beta hat and
so we are always trying to find a good
estimate for the counterfactual but
that's always in service of finding a
good estimate for the treatment
effect so let's think of a way we can
estimate the counteract so I have these
two groups they both didn't go through
the treatment and then one went through
the treatment and I'm trying to
understand what's a good what could have
been for the treatment group and so why
don't I just use the control group
consumption they both went you know they
Geographic balance right so they both
went through the same temperature in the
year 2013 so why don't I use um the
alpha 2013 as the Baseline for beta
hats so this would be great if the
groups um had the same Baseline and so
we can we can check whether or not the
groups have the same consumption
patterns by looking at 2012 data 2012
there's no impact of any SP treatment
and so on the y axis you're seeing the
average consumption per day for both of
those groups and so what this is showing
is that the groups are not balanced and
on average the treatment group is
consuming less than the control group
and so if we had not looked at our data
and if we didn't know this about the
trial um the fact that it was opt in
this could change the dynamic um of the
conception patterns of the groups um we
could have uh falsely assumed um that
there's the same Baseline and then this
could have actually led to the incorrect
result because if we have a lower
consuming treatment group and we compare
it with control group in 2013 you can
actually conclud include that the
treatment group has lowered their
consumption but that's actually not as a
result of the treatment it is just
because they consume less all the
time so turns out I can't use uh the so
why don't I compare them to their own
selves in the previous year right so now
I want some counterfactual some what
would have been um in
2013 but they actually went through
static pricing in 2012 so I'll just use
that data so this is my more
sophisticated night model but also turns
out that things change here a year so in
order to to understand the change
between 2012 2013 we're looking at the
same metric so this is average St
consumption um for the control um and so
what this is showing is that during
parts of the year um the 2013
consumption more is more and during
times of the year the the 2012 T thism
So then again we can't really use this
as the
Baseline so now we've talked about two
things we've talked about the fact that
the groups are not balanced um they do
not have the same um Baseline behavior
and we've also talked about the fact
that the two years created um there's a
change between the years and so this is
going to give us two paths forward for
estimating uh the counterfactual
consumption so this is the first path so
let's look at the the boxes on the top
so if I take the consumption for the
control group in 2012 and map it onto
the consumption for the treatment group
in 2012 and learn what that group
mapping is from uh 2012 and apply it to
2013 I'm taking the same group and let's
assume this group mapping does not
change over time that's a simplifying
assumption that I want to make um then I
can get the counterfactual consumption
so this is the first path I am simply
learning how to map one population onto
another one to get the counter box
consumption
another way to do this is to learn this
other thing that we looked at right like
let's learn the changes based on time so
if I again learn the thing on the left
so let's use data um from 2012 and 2013
for the control group learn what the
changes based on time is then I can
apply that to the treatment group and
get the counteract motion so this put
this shows you two methods of getting
half practical consumption I'm going to
choose the first method
so this is just the mathematical
formulation of that first method right
so the first line is telling you that I
have my control group Matrix for 2012 um
and I have this x that's my mapping
function and uh I have my control so I
want to map the control group onto the
treatment group so I can find X in the
first line because I have data for 2012
um and I can apply it to the second line
to get the counteract consumption so
once I get an estimate for the coun
final consumption I can get an estimate
for the
treatment any
questions
cool all right so we've talked about
these Alpha matrices and beta matrices
in abstract so let's go fill out some
data but there's no Alpha and beta
Matrix so this is the what the raw data
looks like it's actually delivered in
168 CSV files um and you have a couple
of files for um those features that I
talked about for the socioeconomic
features um and the tariffs that were
implemented at different times and so
going back to the to the two lessons
that I talked about one reason that is
important to have some sort of
mathematical model or ref framing um is
that it's going to inform how you want
to read in and process your data and so
given the mathematical formulation that
we just went through I'm going to divide
my data in a way that helps analyze
using that using that model so the first
set of files that I'm going to create um
are going to hold only consumption value
so I want to create my Alpha and beta
matrices using these files so I'm going
to create files that have the unique
house ID um whether or not it was um in
the treating group what half an hour
interval we're talking about and the
consumption for that half hour
interval the other the other file is
going to be that the the socioeconomic
features so we haven't really talked
about them that much but it could be
useful to to bring them in some point so
and I have a unique house ID so um I'm
going to store a file with the unique
house ID and the two socioeconomic
features that I have and so that that
allows me to bring it in at any point
that I
want and lastly Let's uh create the
Tariff file right so this is going to be
the sort of map profile that's going to
tell you at this particular half an hour
point in 2013 the price Model uh the
pricing was low high or medium and so
this is going to help you because
ultimately let's go back to our orig
question our original question was is
this treatment effective in high prices
um because that is the way demand
response would be using this pricing
model and so this third file is going to
help us isolate what those hours
are okay so informed by the model now I
have these files look look how much
nicer that
is um okay so let's go back to our model
right this down here is the model that
we had X is going to be our group
mapping um I can apply it get the
counter factual things are great but
let's go back to our onboarding process
so this is a plot that you've seen
before um it's been made to uh parallel
uh The Matrix that we have so our Matrix
reminder is a t byn and so here again we
have a t t is building up as the year
goes along um and we have n the number
of unique houses so let's go back to the
onboarding process so as 2012 is going
along um they're bringing in more houses
into into the trial and so what this
says kind of like parallelize these two
pictures um actually your Alpha 2012
Matrix is half full and that's also the
case for your beta 2012 Matrix and so
this both poses computational um and
sort of robustness issues right so if
I'm going to learn my group mapping from
two matrices that are actually half full
um that's not going to give me a robust
um math thing so there's some ways
around this I'm going to pose a couple
of paths forward and then take one path
forward so One path forward is that I
want to impute those values so I have
some missing values but I have a lot of
other values so why don't I go learn
something from the other values that I
have and impute these values that I
don't have so there's one positive with
this um there's a lot of positive the
one positive is that I get to keep a lot
of the data that I have right so let's
work off of the assumption that every
data that I have that every data that
I've aggregated um or it accumulated uh
is useful it's teaching you something
useful there's uh there's good trends
that we can distract from that and so
that we can keep the data is a is a
positive
thing um but then this poses some
challenges right so how do we impute the
data um what imputation function do we
use um are we introducing any error
these are all questions that come with
this
method another path forward is let's
limit the time right so there's the the
first half of 2012 where we're on
boarding um but the latter half of 2012
we have a good fraction of our houses
there so why don't we just chop the data
and look at the latter half 2012 for
example so that you know the limitation
is going to be one of the the things the
themes that come up with these Solutions
so this the negative there is that you
can't capture annual seasonality and
with electricity comp consumption um
annual seasonality is right so there's
definitely like an intuitive uh
translation between what the temperature
is like and what the what electricity
consumption is and so if you limit that
you're not going to be able to capture
the anual
anality another path forward is let's
fix a panel of houses and so let me
Define um you know some subset of rules
uh for a house to uh pass through this
filter right so let's um in the more
strict scenario say if a house has all
of the 2012 data they can enter my panel
and so I fix that panel and and only a
subset of houses can enter that uh that
situation and so um what this means is
that I'm getting rid of a lot of houses
given the the onboarding process so
again we have this limitation um
negative but in addition to that let's
go back to our causality um talk right
so I want to study populations but in
order to robustly um create an estimate
I want large populations and this is
going to get rid of a large fraction of
the houses that I
have and lastly another path for it is
let's reduce
dimensionality and so we have these
matrices that are of size T byn but you
can kind of shrink them right so um why
don't I to find aetric find a way to
take it from n and turn it into a vector
of size
one and so what I can do is for any
given T I have some number of houses for
which I have a value and so why don't I
take the mean um over all of the ones
that I have
um to get a single representative value
for half an hour um for every gu during
those
years and so again the negative here
goes back to the same same theme so I
will be getting getting rid of um a lot
of data but how um I will be capturing
some uh value in them right so I'm not
getting rid of them entirely I'm
actually taking the mean along them and
so I I can carry along some of the value
uh that those data points have
so let's kind of think about how how
would you pick a path forward here so
there's really no wrong answer um it
depends on the assumptions that you're
comfortable making and sort of uh that
the lesson perhaps is that you should
make decisions uh that are informed by
the data but then also take into effect
the kind of analysis that you want to
do okay so let's reduce dimensionality
so we have these matrices that are of
size T by n T um or NC and we want to
reduce them from this size to a vector
of size T and so what we're going to do
is for each given T go and take the
average for the values that are there so
this is going to get rid of the N
problem as I call it and so the fact
that some of these T's have fewer houses
than others really goes away in this
situation um and then we end up with a
vector of size
two and so we can rewrite our model um
using vectors of size T so nothing has
really changed um given the way the
matrices were structured all of them in
the scenario will be of size T um and
now my her mapping is is a simple uh
linear fit so what I need to do is use
2012 data to learn A and B so I'm just
fitting a line and I'm applying that
same line to the 2013 data to get the C
factual same story from there I estimate
the counter factual and I estimate the
treatment
effect so this is what the line looks
like
the data looks linear so that's good but
we have this offshoot here and we you
know and and with more time it would be
good to try and understand what this
option is and so sort of like another
lesson is let's say you pick a model you
apply it and you observe something that
doesn't exactly match what you expected
it's good to go back and check figure
out what is this off that you have or
maybe is linear as a linear model um a
good uh choice in this situation but
let's see if we can do a little bit
better than
that so let's go back to our Matrix so
we have these values T we're building up
but also we have unique house IDs and we
have socioeconomic features for these
house IDs so let me see if I can kind of
use those features to see if the impact
of this pricing model was different
between the different socioeconomic
groups and so I can divide my metric
into um different socio economic
categories um because I have the unique
house IDs and and I know what the
socioeconomic value is um socioeconomic
category is for those um and so with
that I can instead of fitting one line
uh fit three lines so it's the same
linear fit um I'm now just dividing the
matrices into socioeconomic
subcategories and then doing that
dimensionality reduction uh on each of
those soci economic groups and so these
are the different lines that you're
getting they're not that different but
they're different um they all have that
option so um
and um you can apply the line on your
2013 data to get that counter factual
and now you have an estimate for your
treatment so this is what your treatment
estimate looks like it is also a vector
of size team but let's go back to the
original question the original question
was what is the effect of this treatment
on high price
hours and so one of the other files that
we had is a Terra file so so I know per
half an hour um in 2013 what price was
implemented and so the goal is for me to
understand more importantly the effect
of this uh pricing model on the high
price
hours okay so in the title I had
something about Python and mathematical
modeling we've been talking a lot about
mathematical modeling but where's the
python and all
this so to me um which kind of this tied
back to the second point Point um of the
talk um python is a very useful tool so
the mapping between matrices and vectors
which is what we've been talking about
to python is fairly intuitive um but
also it's important to ground your work
in a mathematical model and mathematical
Framing and then the python will just
sort of like flow from there let's talk
about a particular case where the
Python's very useful so T adversity um
is that treatment estimate um of size T
so going back to
365 time 48 that's the 17,000 20 um and
so that is my treatment estimate um
Vector of size te and the thing that I
want to learn let's go back to the
previous picture is I want to isolate to
the time intervals uh that had high
price
points and so I also have a file that
tells me um what the terar at any given
point in time so this high it's going to
tell me the half an hour intervals that
had high price
points and so what I want to do is go to
my Vector of size T and find only those
intervals that had high price points um
and find what the treatment effect is
there so I can do that very easily using
a panda Series so I'm turning my um
column Vector into a row Vector using
this reshape and I'm passing in the
index that has half an hour intervals
for 2013 um and with that I can simply
look up do a do look and look up the the
time intervals um that have high price
points and so um now I can conclude that
there was 12% sheding in those times
this is already in percent space so I'm
thinking the mean over all of those uh
High half an hours um and so getting a
single value um for the treatment effect
for the adversity group multiplying by
100 just to take it into percent space
any questions
there so so what panas allows do um is
that you can use panas very easily with
time series data and so I could do this
um if if I didn't have panas it would um
it would take much longer it would be
more
difficult um so here are some results um
so we have our three soci economic
categories and we have our three
segmentation of uh of price overall just
takes everything into one but let's go
back to the original question again we
care about the impact during these price
points and so on average um the
adversity and comfortable group have
shed Demand by 12% and the Asing group
has shed Demand by
4.51% so here we can conclude that going
back to the effectiveness metric that we
defined for this for this pricing model
um that our treatment was effective in a
lowering consumption in the in the times
of high
demand so let's go back to the lessons
so there were a lot of decisions that we
made throughout this journey um a lot of
them were informed uh by our knowledge
uh of the data so the fact that it was
opt in the fact that there was a fill
rate issue um and the fact that we have
larger populations and so it's both on
the negative side so understanding the
the shortfalls and the biases but also
understanding the strengths of your data
is going to help you guide um the
analysis uh you know steps forward um
and uh it is important to do that
and so
secondly I'm almost done um secondly it
is important to have some model grounded
um in real world and uh Guided by first
principles and then jump into the data
um and try to fit a model U to your data
and so that's that diagram you start
from reality you have some understanding
um of the mathematical framework that
you want to apply and that guides both
your analysis but then also how you
clean up your data and how you construct
um your your data so with that um if you
want to learn more that's my
thesis